this is All That Remains of the mosque
in the police compound in Peshawar
investigators say a suicide bomber blew
himself up during afternoon prayers
hundreds of worshipers were inside
the mosque is in a highly fortified Red
Zone which includes a police
headquarters and a counter-terrorism
unit raising concerns about a major
security breach
it is a matter of great condemnation
that terrorists can enter a government
Department if the government Department
don't have security what safety can they
provide us
a faction of the harika Taliban Pakistan
the Pakistani Taliban claimed
responsibility saying it's the fourth
suicide attack in retaliation for the
killing of Khalid horasani one of its
senior leaders in Afghanistan last year
but the group's leadership has since
distanced itself from the bombing saying
holy places should not be targeted
prime minister Shabbat Sharif has
condemned the attack and promised Stern
action he says terrorism is a country's
biggest security challenge
the Pakistani Taliban has threatened and
targeted Security forces in recent weeks
this is not the first time this kind of
bombing has happened since 2006
thousands of people have lost their
lives and we have had enough of
terrorism
in November the group ended the
ceasefire with the Pakistani government
and earlier this month released this
video of Fighters training promising
more attacks and declaring its intention
to impose a Hardline interpretation of
Islamic law
the group has been waging a war against
the Pakistani government for more than a
decade last year it carried out at least
150 attacks killing dozens of people
analysts say the group has been
emboldened since the talibans returned
to power in Afghanistan in August of
2021.
it's evident that harika Taliban is
targeting Security Forces once again
even in places of worship
Al Jazeera